[Music]
the Tour de France's is the pinnacle of
the cycling calendar I have to be there
in the best form possible that's the
race to win year-on-year the levels just
getting higher and higher and the
margins are getting thinner and thinner
so it's definitely gonna be a tight race
I think fueling is gonna be paramount so
time to sport gels more bars you need to
be drinking just as much as well the
stage racing obviously the key thing is
recovery but at the same time when
you're actually racing on the bike
fuelling property then as well because
if you you know end the stage and the
deficit it's hard to replace all that
I'm recovered for the next day - a good
variety of gels and you know even the
protein gels want some of the longer
stages one of the most important things
is getting a very good quality recovery
drink as soon as you can after finishing
the stage so your body can use
everything in there the amino acids that
the right balance of proteins and carbs
to replenish a depleted glycogen levels
and everything else that you've used
during the stage that's where the
recovery process begins as soon as we
finish the stage we're straight to the
person we have our regalo straightaway
about 20 minute window straight after
exercises where you need to have the
recovery in you really you know it's
just about being on the ball from from
the get-go really you know get the right
stuff into you it's crucial reads
ravenous strong and being strong through
the whole three weeks